but I want to bring in now former
Arkansas governor and Fox News
contributor Mike Huckabee great to see
you today governor one of the things
that I would just add into the mix here
because I watched that live with the
president earlier and you know he did
say that if he sees something that's
going south in terms of how people are
social distancing in certain areas that
he's going to snap back with a response
and we've seen him do that before and I
think that's exactly what we ought to be
doing
we took a draconian action as a nation
frankly everybody did in the whole world
because we really weren't sure just how
fast this virus would what would begin
to move now we have a much better
picture of it we've seen that mitigation
works I think the president is right
open the economy back up let governors
make the decisions and local mayors and
county officials and then if there does
spring up another problem address the
problem but don't shut everybody thirty
million people out of work because we
know what that's doing to us and it's
destroying not just the economy it's
destroying the spirit and the will and
the resilience of Americans and that's
our greatest asset you know who agrees
with you is former governor of New
Jersey chris Christie and he had these
very raw words to say about reopening
watch I think that's what we need from
governor's now is some boldness and some
ingenuity and honesty to the people in
the end you're gonna have to tell them
people are going to die and it's going
to be awfully sad where are those vibes
going to be worth if people can't go to
work if they can't support their
families if they're gonna become
homeless you know if they have to go to
food banks every week to be able to feed
their families that that's not
sustainable either
governor Huckabee our other governor is
going to be willing to do that to
sacrifice lives along the way I don't
think it's a matter of sacrificing lives
a lot of us have done what we've done
not because we were scared for ourselves
but we didn't want to subject other
people to the anxieties or potentially
if we were carrying the virus I think
now we're at a point where we're able to
say to people if you're nervous and just
fearful that you're one of those people
vulnerable stay home stay out of the
world
but the rest of us are going to get back
to living we can't stay hunkered down in
bunkers for the rest of our lives and so
if we go out we go out knowing there's
perhaps a risk but I'll tell you there's
no risk in continuing to shut the
economy down we know what happens when
that takes place we all start to suffer
we see that and I think a lot of
Americans are saying a few of us may get
sick but we're all hurting right now
because none of us have been able to go
out for the last eight weeks yeah I want
to move on to this the president taking
some heat and some questions if you will
about why he will not let dr. pouchy
testify before the house first Senate's
gonna go watch the houses are set up the
house is a bunch of Trump haters they
put every Trump painter on the committee
the same old stuff they frankly want our
situation to be unsuccessful which means
death which means death and our
situation is going to be very successful
wow those are some pretty strong words
against the opposing party governor well
it's a pretty strong nonsense that the
opposing party has thrown at the
president from the phony impeachment
nonsense to the fact that every day they
blame him for something else regarding
the corona virus when in fact he has
responded so well that he has Democrat
governors who don't even like him saying
nice things about him and appreciating
the fact that he has been responsive to
them the reason that dr. Falchi
shouldn't go and testify to Congress is
because the conversations and
discussions that he has had with the
president are in the executive branch
where they should remain if you take
conversations candid conversations that
a president can have with the people
surrounding him and you start having
politically charged hateful people like
exist in the Democrat House just trying
to expose it and cause trouble in the
midst of a pandemic presidents will
never surround themselves with people
like dr. Fauci again that's the danger
that we would face not that we won't
know what dr. fowey thinks I think it's
pretty clear Harris this is not a guy
who is
shrinking violet he goes and says what
he thinks right in the presence of the
president but the president's not going
to truck these people off to Congress so
that they can get skewered by the likes
of Adam Schiff interesting Ari Fleischer
on with me last hour on outnumbered said
perhaps you let the Senate go first and
then the house comes second so everybody
gets a bite I said you know there are
Democrats in the Senate they can ask
questions too why do you have to be in
the majority to ask the questions
can't you just participate but that's
just my take by the way
May 12th the Senate hearing will see
doctor foul Qi and CDC director Redfield
in front of the Senate so we will talk
at that time good to see you
governor Huckabee always thank you thank
you Harris